here we are with Carrie Washington and
before the break we ask an audience
member named Crystal which is a below
fact about Carrie is true and they to
just refresh a car's nickname was condom
Carrie in high school B carry swam
across the English Channel or C Carrie
got dance lessons from Janet Jackson
Crystal what do you think a b or c well
I do know that you used to swim in high
school I know you're friends with Janet
I've been watching Instagram
but but I think it's that condom carry
crystal that is
[Applause]
correct now are we going to give some
context cuz that's that's a little
scandalous well I thought it might be
the possibility because it was so random
but what is the context of condom carry
so I was in an educational Theater
Company in high school where we used to
perform plays around safe for sex
education to get teenagers to make
choices that were really good for them
so we were helping kids make decisions
to save their lives and I worked at an
adolescent Health Center where we used
to give out condoms for free and so I
always had condoms in my backpack Goen
condom
[Applause]
carry crystal since you won we want to
give you a copy of Carrie's book with
$500 folded into it to just spend on a
little
ch um when you got married yes it was a
very private ceremony you were very
protective of it smart yes um there were
code names involved was condom Cary one
of them no no it was getting married no
condoms um right you don't need them
anymore that's exactly some fun code
names so Jason Woo um made my wedding
gown and I I adore him he's the person
who made Michelle Obama's inaugural gown
and um so he was custom secretly custom
making this wedding gown for me but we
used to say that it was for the Moroccan
premiere of Scandal and everybody was
like okay now all I've seen all over
Instagram is you and Tony
Goldwin the book tour I me he was so
sweet to be in conversation with me on
the tour but people love you
I know is
there I mean what you did with Scandal
yeah he's just an amazing allround human
being he really is will we ever see you
too on screen again I would be lucky to
have that opportunity I don't know that
there's a scandal reboot or anything
like that I mean you'd have to ask Sean
the movie I don't know Shonda Rhymes
Netflix h i get her on the show put her
in the chair
ask her oh my God I just love her so
much is she nice what she like she's the
best I'm obsessed with her she's really
she is one
of is it so good yes I love it she's so
wonderful she's so supportive she's an
incredible boss a beautiful friend she
actually like bought tickets and sent
students to my places on book tour so
that young people could come and hear me
speak in cities I mean she's just like
an amazing human being when I told her
and you know this when you get pregnant
on a job sometimes your bosses are less
than thrilled they're not allowed to be
legally but they can sometimes be upset
yeah Shonda had none of that when I told
Shonda I was pregnant she literally
jumped up and down in my trailer was
just like purely happy for me threw me
my baby shower like was so generous
about her process and gave me resources
and support and she's just a beautiful
human she really inspired me to think
about the kind of boss that want to be
in the world did you talk to her about
writing B she was one of the first
people who wrote who who wrote who read
the book When It Was Written she was one
of the first people I sent it to my
parents and my husband before I sent it
to anybody um but she was in that first
round of friends who I was like do you
have any notes any feedback any anything
she gave me brilliant notes um and she's
really she's just so
[Music]
supportive